[Music]
good afternoon my name is Sophie grace
chuckle I am the professor of philosophy
at the Open University and you should
probably be able to see my contact
details there if you want to get in
touch with me about this talk I want to
talk today about my current research
which is about epiphanies and I'm going
to start by explaining what epiphanies
are and giving a few examples and saying
why I think they're worth studying and
why there's something maybe that we can
learn from them so most of my research
has been in the area of philosophy that
we call moral philosophy or ethics it's
also called sometimes the philosophy of
value though the name the philosophy of
value covers other things as well such
as aesthetics and thinking about reasons
and what we have reason to believe as
well as what we have reason to do but
what really struck me about ethics as a
way of doing the philosophy of value is
that a lot of the time it just seemed
very distant from our actual experiences
of value from what we take as being
valuable in our lives and I came across
a striking passage in one of my favorite
books this one here ethics and the
limits of philosophy by Bernard Williams
well William says there could be a
philosophy of experience there could be
a philosophy of value in which we
started
not from theories moral theories like
utilitarianism the thing to do is bring
about the greatest happier happiness to
the greatest number or kantianism the
thing to do is act always upon that
Maxim that you can at the same time will
should be the maxim of every rational
being in a kingdom of ends instead of
starting from those points we could
start the philosophy of value and we
could start ethics by thinking about
experience by thinking about the way we
actually live and what matters to us in
our own experience of life another book
that was enormously important to me and
still is in thinking about this is this
book the sovereignty of good by Iris
Murdoch and in some ways what I want to
today is if you like a sort of a sort of
mashup of things that are in Murdoch and
Williams although I don't mean by that
that either Murdoch or Williams would
necessarily approve of what I have to
say so I thought about this I'm
destroying as I saw it between our own
experience of value the way we
experience value as we live and the
philosophy of value and in particular
ethics where it was all about theories
and it was like the difference between
well ordinary life and some peculiar
kind of parade-ground
drill and I wondered if there might be a
way for philosophy to break out of the
constrictions as I see them of moral
theory where we're only thinking all the
time about whether a particular action
or particular rule of action would fit
with that moral theory whether we could
think in it perhaps free away or maybe a
more dangerous way a more risky way
about what it is to be a human being in
this world what it is to be aware of
value what it is to live a life in which
you try and get hold of values and when
I started thinking in that way and
started thinking about the notion of an
experience of value my attention was
drawn straightaway to those experiences
of value where things become focal for
us where values become specially clear
to us where we experience some value
with particular vividness and that's
what I mean by an epiphany the word has
been around a long time this word
epiphany it's there
originally of course in Greek it's a
Greek word after Eddie Familia and in
Greek it means a revelation and often it
means the revelation of the divine so in
the Christian Church there's a festival
of epiphany on January the 6th
celebrated 12 days after Christmas
itself and depending on how you count
exactly your days and the festival of
iffen II is about the revelation of
divine value in the human world before
that epiphany was often used by
pre-christian Greeks by pagan Greeks to
talk
man you to the word did entertain the
meaning that particularly interested me
until the 20th century and it attained
it through James Joyce he was writing in
a book called Steven Hiro which was the
prototype of portrait of the artist as a
young man in which he is his hero who is
called Stephen Dedalus says well what we
have to do is try and capture these
evanescent moments in which we
experience something particularly
spirituals something particularly
valuable
those are epiphanies and it would be
good to try and write a book in which we
write those epiphanies down and in fact
James Joyce did write such a book that
was called Dubliners Dubliners is a
study of various sorts of epiphanies in
the kind of sense I'm talking about so
what is that sense well let me start
with some examples here's an example
from my own life this picture was taken
by my partner we were supposed to be
going climbing but it was a good day for
skiing and we ended up only skiing this
is me looking over the edge of the lair
it grew with a cloud see in the lair it
grew and it was an epidemic moment for
me being up there and it's that snow and
all that beauty with a Blazing Sun in
the sky and with perfect snow for skiing
and of course one of the reasons why
this is such a great picture that Steven
took of me it's because it's immediately
reminded me
subconsciously without my realizing I
was being reminded of this picture he
death I think in that picture I look a
little bit like the wanderer above the
sea of fog and I was Alondra above the
sea of fog when Caspar David Friedrich
painted this very famous image which is
famously used as the cover for the
penguin edition of Nietzsche's the
Antichrist Friedrich was clearly
thinking of a moment of Epiphany where
someone reaches the top of the mountain
and sees below them the glorious world
spread out before them in this
magnificent way so that's an example of
an epiphany from the Romantic era but to
stress it again in the Romantic era
although they clearly have the notion
of an epiphany a moments of Revelation
of value they don't seem to have had the
word the word had to wait for joist
roughly a century after Friedrich
painted this picture another kind of
Epiphany I'm going to want to say that
epiphany scant acres in all sorts of
directions because they're revelations
of value in experience they can be
revelations both a positive and a
negative value they can be revelations
of beauty they can be revelations if you
believe in the theological of
theological understanding they can be
revelations of things that excite us not
only to love and admiration but also to
pity to excitement um they can be
intellectual the epiphanies can be
intellectual like the famous moments I
don't have a picture of this
fortunately perhaps where Archimedes got
out of his bath and ran through the
streets shouting Eureka Eureka Eureka
Eureka as we say in English because he
just realized that a way to measure the
mass of a solid was to stick it in some
water because that displaces the water
and that was an intellectual Epiphany
this here in Caravaggio is very famous
painting is a moment of Revelation of
value it's the moment when the disciples
who have taken in the stranger as
they're walking to Emmaus they get to
amass they take in this mysterious
hooded stranger
shortly after Jesus has been crucified
and over stuff that they suddenly
realized that the stranger unhooded now
and blessing the bread and the wine is
Jesus himself and this is Caravaggio's
wonderful painting of that moment of
Epiphany um in the book that I'm writing
at the moment I find myself talking a
number of times about epiphanies
involving plane trees one of them was an
epiphany at my own in Mecklenburg Square
in Bloomsbury in London where they have
magnificent flame trees one afternoon I
rushed into a hotel room in Mecklenburg
Square I rushed upstairs I was all the
sweat I was completely panting and
frustrated and fed up and I opened the
window and met him back to square if you
go there if you happen to live in London
and if you're allowed out if you're
close enough to Mecklenburg Square to
walk there you'll be able to see this
for your
today and perhaps today would be a good
day to do it um the plain trees in
Mecklenburg Square as soon as I looked
out of that window upstairs in a hotel
bedroom all Crosse and bothered all
sweaty and fed up with the hassle of
traveling and all the things that were
bothering me at the time I looked out of
the window and the plane tree the plane
trees of Mecklenburg Square took my
breath away because they were beautiful
they took me out of myself
they made me aware not of myself my own
worries but of the world around me and
in that sense they did me good
and here's another every fanuc plane
tree this is a plane tree in the grounds
of Northern College Oxford one of my
favorite places and here is a great
plain tree which if you're lucky enough
to be in that place you can't go there
at the moment unfortunately but when it
reopens it's worth visiting just to see
this beautiful plain tree this
magnificent um moment of glory in nature
which is the maudlin plain I recommend
it
it will do you good so there are some
examples of epiphanies and what I want
to say about them perhaps it's time for
something like a definition of
epiphanies these are examples of
epiphanies what's the definition you
might be thinking philosophers very keen
on definitions and again this is another
point where I wanted to veer a little
away from the normal main current of
philosophy because although I think I
can give you something like a definition
of epiphany it's not and if and only if
definition is philosophers say it's not
a tight and exclusive all-or-nothing
definition either things are epiphanies
and they fit the definition or they're
not epiphanies and they don't fit the
definition and if there are borderline
cases then I'm supposed to be worried
about that well because I'm a
philosopher of experience and because I
think experience is a rather messy thing
Noah nearest ideas philosophers
categories I'm quite happy to say that
the notion of an epiphany is something
which has focal cases but it's also
something which has blurry edges there
can be questions about whether something
is an epiphany at all there can be
questions about whether something just
as there can be questions about whether
something is a wave or
waves if you like our peaks in the
surface of the sea or indeed other kinds
of waves apiece and other kinds of wave
stream um different is our peaks in in
the waves of experience and we shouldn't
expect there to be anything very neat to
be said about where a wave begins and
ends it's like that with epiphanies they
shade off into the rest of our stream of
experience and in the end my interest in
the current research project is not just
in epiphanies it's in the whole
continuum the whole planer
of our lived experience in which
epiphanies are the peaks and I think
they say something particularly
interesting about that experience but
they're not the only thing that's worth
studying to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a IDOT TV for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas